احمر. حذر رئيس وزراء العراق
مصطفى الكاظمي من ان العراق يمر
النجمة الكبرى المسبتة على
الصولجان الملكي. خلال يوم اقتحم
السفير الاسرائيلي الجديد جيل
ارتزيم. انتشرت مقاطع فيديو
سنستثني تركيا دون اوروبا وسيكون
لها وضع ليزرع الشك مجددا في
موضعنا لبنانيون خمسة مصارف
تجارية في عدد من المدن
عدة حول اسباب تحسن العلاقات
التركية السورية مؤخرا. تركيا
ملفات ساخنة تناقشها القمة من
بينها حرب اوكرانيا والوضع في
سوريا والازمة التي يعانيها
الاقتصاد التركي مع استمرار سعر
ان يكون الانتظار امام عدسات
الكاميرات في قمة دولية يترقبها
ذكرت صحيفة فاينالشال تايمز ان
بنج طلب من قواته التحضير
ويدعو الى تشكيل نظام عالمي جديد
عادل ديمقراطي ليضع هنا الجانب
يلوي الالمان ذراع بوتين بهذه
الخطوة? ليظهر هنا السحر الهندي.
الى حوار الطاولات. وخلال لقاء
جمع الزعيمين في سمرقند
قائلا هناك ادلة على جرائم حرب
ارتكبتها روسيا. ووفقا للشرطة
وجرحوا خلال قصف روسي على مواقع
اوكرانية في مقاطعات خرسون وذلك
اخر قائلا. موسكو تحاول تغييرا
العالمي القائم. لتعلن هنا وزارة
بلسان ايجور كوناشينكوف المتحدث
باسم وزارة الدفاع الروسي لتأتي
طالبت جنوب افريقيا العائلة
الملكية البريطانية باعادة ماسة
جراد بيد الالمان. التكتيك
السوفيتي حينها كان يسعى لكسب
يقصد? هل سمعتم من قبل بخطة
ستالين جراد وتكتيك سوفيتي قلب
مقاتل وثمانمائة واكثر من مائة
مقاتلة جو ليطبق هنا خطة
جدية اذا واجهت روسيا تهديدا
خطيرا. هكذا قالها بوتين فماذا
الاسد لو حضر قمة منظمة شنجاي في
اوزباكستان وهو ما اثار تساؤلات
باستثناء روسيا ان تزود اوروبا
بكميات كافية من الغاز. مرة اخرى
ازمة سياسية قد تكون الاصعب بعد
عام الفين وثلاثة. مضيفا ان هناك
امن ومستقر. الصين وروسيا تعلنان
عن عالم جديد. بينما بوتين
العراقي من هذه الكارثة. تكتيك
روسي جديد. سنتصرف بشكل اكثر
المصافي. مبررة ذلك بضمان
امدادات الطاقة الوطنية. فهل
على مطالبه المحقة وبدء استخراج
النفط والغاز من حقل كريش خط
خمسة وعشرين في المائة من واردات
الغاز الروسي. نعم قال لها بوتين
تظهر دولة تطالب باحدى الماسات
التي تزين ملوك بريطانيا اذ
اللبنانية من بينها مصرف غربي
العاصمة بيروت. حسن نصر الله. لا
دعما لفلسطين. الرئيس التشيلي
جابرييل بوريك يرفض اعتماد
املا بايجاد حلول لتجاوز هذه
الازمة من اجل العبور نحو عراق
الامارات في دوتشمان في ابو ظبي
بحضور كبار الشخصيات الاماراتية.
لاحتفال اليهود بزفاف الحاخام
وممثل الجالية اليهودية في
لانعاش اقتصاد انقرة وذلك من
خلال مساعدة روسية لتخفيض
يمكن السماح باستخراج النفط
والغاز من كريش قبل حصول لبنان
يمكن تحمل اذا استمرت في الطريق
الخطأ. برأيكم هل سيصدق كل
الاستقرار في العالم المضطرب.
ليكشف الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
اوكرانيا نافيا صحة المزاعم
الاوكرانية بان الروس يرفضون
العالم اجمع انتظر بوتين اردوغان
قرابة دقيقة بغرفة الاجتماعات في
الدفاع والتكنولوجيا في روسيا.
ومن اصوات الرصاص وازيز الطائرات
ليتلقى ردا قاسيا وبتصريح رسمي
من بكين. واشنطن ستدفع ثمنا لا
الامريكي حينها بالتدخل عسكريا
في حال هاجمت الصين تايوان
نعم. الصين مستعدة للعمل مع
روسيا ولعب دور قيادي لضخ
الاسعار في تركيا وتحويل مدفوعات
الغاز لليرة التركية والفوز بخصم
التعليقات. شركة جاز بروما
الروسية انه لا يمكن لاي دولة
واشنطن ويحاول تعديل مسار العالم
الجديد الذي دعت اليه روسيا
تمد يدها لسوريا فهل لبوتين
علاقة بذلك? الاحداث والتطورات
والصين. بوتين يؤيد سياسة الصين
الواحدة معارضا لاستفزازات
حكمة لم يعلم ما في احشائها الا
اصحاب العيون الضيقة. طاولة
تم تداوله على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي. اهالخبثك يا لقد
بشأن الحرب الاوكرانية ولم يوضح
يحدد نقطة الخلاف. ومن جانبها
ترتعي من الخوف من هول ما سمعت
ليسمع صراخها ابناء العم سام في
قمة سمرقند في خطوة يراها
مراقبون بانها متعمدة من اردوجان
واشنطن لبكين في تايوان ليبتسم
هنا شي جين بينغ. يكمل بوتين
قلوب الغربيين. اردوغان يرغب
ايضا في لقاء نظيره السوري بشار
الليرة التركية. اذ يسعى اردوجان
خلال هذه القمة للاستنجاد ببوتين
بوتين في اجتماعه عن وجود خلاف
بوجهات النظر مع نظيره الصيني
ليست نهاية الحرب. ليعزز رئيس
اللجنة العسكرية للناتو بتصريح
للسيطرة على تايوان عام الفين
وسبعة وعشرين ليتعهد الرئيس
قليلا هنا. هل شراء الغاز الروسي
لا يمول الحرب? وهل الغاز القادم
ضاعفت عطشهم للطاقة وبشأن
الطاقة. الحكومة الالمانية تعلن
الحطب هكذا سخر رئيس بلاروسيا من
الدول الاوروبية في مقطع فيديو
انتقاما لموقف تعرض له قبل عامين
اثناء لقاء الرئيسين في موسكو.
الى اوروبا? لا يمول الحرب.
تحالف الكبار. عدو عدوي صديقي.
بوعده? وهل ستتدخل امريكا في حال
هاجمت الصين تايوان? ملفات تركية
مجبرة عنها. الهند تستورد النفط
من روسيا لتبيعه للدول
الصيني النقاط على الحروف.
سنواجه التغييرات في العالم.
وبلسان ستولتنبرغ. الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد فعال ولكنها
هنا العقوبات من الخزانة
الامريكية وعلى رأس الرئيس
روسية ساخنة. اكثر ما يجرح
الانسان هو الانتظار. فما بالك
الشيشاني رمضان قديروف كما
استهدفت العقوبات الجديدة قطاعي
الاوروبية. هنا وزير الخارجية
الهندي قائلا دعونا نكون منصفين
وضع يدها على نشاطات مجموعة
الروسية في والتي تدير الكثير من
الدفاع الروسية ان اكثر من
اربعمائة عسكري اوكراني قتلوا
اربعمائة واربعين شخصا في
الاراضي التي تم استعادتها من
هو ليس سحرا بل حيلة ماكرة تحاول
الدول الاوروبية ان تغمض عينيها
ايادي القوات الروسية ليحمل
الزينيسكي الجانب الروسي
المسئولية كاملة طالبا محاسبته
ليظهر هنا الجانب الروسي نافيا
باوزباكستان قال بوتين انه يدرك
مخاوف الهند بشأن الحرب في
المفاوضات. لن ندع اوروبا تتجمد
هذا الشتاء. ومن وسط ركام من
انخراطها مواجهة عسكرية حتمية.
ليظهر الرئيس الاوكراني الزينسكي
اراضي اقليم دومباز بالكامل.
لنعد الى الكرم الامريكي.
الاوكرانية فقد عثرت على مقبرة
جماعية في ايزيوم لاكثر من
الامريكية لتكون زلة لسان كما
اعتدنا من العجوز بايدن ليسأله
نحن لن نعلق في هذا الفيديو بل
سنترك لكم المجال لنرى ارائكم في
هو تكهن ام معلومات استخباراتية
سقطت سهوا بيد الاستخبارات
الصحفي فماذا لو فعلتها روسيا
بايدن? ردنا سيكون مرتبطا بما
بوتين يصرح بانه سيستمر الجيش
الروسي في عملياته العسكرية في
في السن. ان استخدام موسكو اسلحة
نووية او كيميائية في حربها على
هذه الاخبار والتي اسماها مزاعم
اوكرانية لا صحة لها. الناتو
اوكرانيا دون اي تغيير. واضاف ان
هدف العملية هو السيطرة على جميع
ليستشيط الروس غضبا. ويكرر
تحذيرات لواشنطن لان ذلك يعني
امتناعا بل تأجيل وهذا دليل على
عزم النية على الاستئناف مستقبلا
تراجع امريكي عن تزويد اوكرانيا
بصواريخ بعيدة المدى وليس
الكماشة. ويعلن حينها الجيش
الالماني استسلامه ولم يتوقف
اوكرانيا سيغير وجه الحرب بصورة
لم تحدث منذ الحروب العالمية. هل
نفس السيناريو? ومن غبار الحرب
العالمية الثانية الى هذا الطاعم
وتحذيرات بوتين من ارسال صواريخ
بعيدة المدى لاوكرانيا. نعم هنا
سيقوم به بوتين في كل الحالات
سيكون هناك رد امريكي. وهنا
الجيش الاحمر الا في قلب العاصمة
الالمانية برلين. هذه الاحداث
الكثير من الوقت ليعيد تموضعه
وليحشد حينها اكثر من مليون
الى الجنود الى نهر بولجا تاركا
تسعين بالمائة من مدينة ستالين
تتشابه مع ما يحدث حاليا في
اوكرانيا. فهل يخطط بوتين لاعادة
استدرج الجيش الالماني الى العمق
الروسي ما صعب ايصال الامدادات
موازين الحرب الثانية عام الف
وتسعمائة واثنين واربعين عندما
بروسيا لانقاذها وهذه الدولة
ترفض تعيين سفير لاسرائيل فيما
بينما الجيش الروسي يحضر لتكتيك
عسكري جديد وفيديو للرئيس
ابناء زايد يوجهون طعنة جديدة
الفلسطيني والكاظمي يحذر الشعب
سنستخدم كل قوتنا اذا واجهنا اي
تهديد وجودي. نحن لا نلعب. هكذا
ضد موسكو وزلة لسان تجعل بيض
يفضح سرا استخباراتيا يضعه في
البلاروسي يتسبب بنوبة غضب لدول
اوروبا باكملها. وتركيا تستنجد
قالها بوتين بينما الصين تعلن عن
حربها الجديدة. فعن اي حرب
موقف محرج والرئيس الاوكراني
يناشد العالم ويكشف عن فاجعة.
تتحدثون يا اصحاب العيون الضيقة.
حلف الناتو يتوعد باجراء عسكري
يستثني تركيا برأيكم كيف ستكون
ردة فعل الجانب الاوروبي.